Oh with all the slurping good morning
good morning my club good morning a
copyright violation we need to file a
hard strike that's a trademark whole big
penis that's kind of yeah it's a that
are really glad to have you today yeah
we have no guests because we realize a
lot of people club don't want guests
that's my half Asian Larry polish
minutes here hey and look right next to
them there is a Gibbon your boy are you
given hey tell them what your race is so
I am Norwegian Danish Welsh and 1/4
remember I said relax relax bring in I
do I am partially Welsh like the lady
from Frasier wait is yeah you look very
black when you're dressed like the
husband and lady in the [ __ ] getting
chop suey to cue Maddie's on overlays
Gerald a how are you sir doing very well
good morning worse and I'm good to go um
we've a lot to get to we do have some
information that's stumbled upon that no
one else seems to be talking about they
seem to have missed I know it's hard to
trust a guy in a bathrobe but but do
give it your best effort of course got a
lot of credit calm /schedule by the way
so you can see all of the what is this
this is down here I see I have to look
out on my iPad a lot of code that comes
Plus schedule so you can see all of our
broadcasts we have you in the morning we
have them at night it is mud club corn
so money entering the promo code
quarantine you get $30 off if you're
renewing just do it please yeah because
this is what keeps us afloat and we are
trying to give you as much content as
humanly possible
ok given let's give it another quick
check yes sir so I
[Laughter]
charity all right all right look Steven
because I'm a quarter okay now and okay
oh yeah I thought it was Italian for the
longest time order okay now so how did
that is there like a military history in
your family is that how it happened
even if you didn't know Gerald's name
and you didn't and all you heard was
Gerald's voice and even if you didn't
hear his voice you just saw a transcript
of that question you would know Gerald
was an old white guy I get that question
all the times your dad in the military
and know he smoked a lot of weight give
an answer sorry what's your answer given
that's read your researcher has given me
a new updates that's enough Fred you
don't need to give me the updates from
all the news right now he's like adding
when it changes the absent days down to
nine grace so I guess right now there is
a we can bring this up to cute Maddy CBS
just post an article that New York City
has to dig mass burial pits for everyone
who's died from Co vid so I guess their
tweet doesn't claim it we've got the the
it's trending under Trump burial pits
what was that it was just a little
something all right get that right
someone's gonna be like that the voices
someone's gonna be collecting double the
checks because you'll be unemployed so
you'll make more money we have the video
okay from the tweet there we go do we
have it let me see it there we go okay
there we go
real pissed right so uh to be clear Hart
island is actually where any unclaimed
bodies without next of kin are buried
regardless of what they died from so
they've been using it for this purpose
since 1881 around a million people are
buried there so I just want to be clear
you can kind of hear a portion of his
story with Kovac but not the entirety of
it certainly not the context and that
matters so we're going to get to the
death rates and I want to talk about
this quite a bit because everyone just
got really quiet get this fine yeah not
death from Kovac you did they're lying
about it and we're gonna catch them as
funny that is
right yeah your dad told me was like
nobody's getting out of here alive oh my
god that's a horrible argument that's
good way to put it yeah no it's not a
good way to put it because they're alive
but I would rather get out of here like
and have 85 years before I get out of
exactly he didn't say now yeah I know
but even timestamp this is a terrible
show so before before we move on to the
death rates and rhett and Link and a
couple of other things today given we
had no idea I thought it was Italian for
like nine months and Bill where's Ben is
half asian but it turns out I noticed
the day when we were doing the Gyeonggi
video game livestream Gibbon was I mean
I turned you I said menu you like you
got some Sun you need to put on some
aloe vera and I was like crap there's a
shortage and then I realized ya know you
just had half a beer right yes okay so
we want to test this because race is not
imaginary it's real
and so this more science they are going
to leave this off and have a countdown
timer to see how long it takes to get to
the point of rosacea it's time for our
in-studio
Asian rosacea
okay good so now a half-asian bill
Richman is by the way real outcome
you're taking your chat live on the
blaze as well so let us know who you
think is going to rosacea off first that
happen to face off film with Nick Cage
and John Travolta I have no idea I'm
gonna take my face we've got some we've
got some bourbon bourbon alright and did
you both pour it it's both pour drink it
have it alright drink it right now and
then do we timer we have a timer for the
audience I mean no one set a stopwatch
if we don't have a timer for the alright
sit a stopwatch so we've got they've got
a countdown oh they do have a count we
use that for let's just a countdown we
have five minutes you know drink it
all of it all of it liquor in the
morning is good liquor in the morning is
good yeah well he said he thinks that he
might keel over dead pretty quickly
I feel like 30 years from now mind you
phone with a YouTube or Google later
yeah I don't want to be the one carrying
that weight yeah and by the way for
reference we can have a color scale
compared to my this is terrible does
people even understand why your what was
glue I talked about it yesterday yeah I
have my foot a nice bath right now did
ya yes
and Gerald give me horrible medical
advice I found out that you are not
supposed to keep it in the pool of ice
for more than 10 minutes oh crap you
don't know anything about anything every
train let me bring this let's talk about
the death rates if you guys been
following us I have yes I lost sleep
over this by the way and I want to know
this is something I'm very curious about
two people out there how many people
watching right now does anyone have
coronavirus do you have any of you
actually contracted Co vid 19 I forget
the number sometimes like what are we
are we on 22 19 yeah and do you know
anyone who's died from coronavirus I
want to know people out there what this
is anecdotal but of course we see the
data and sometimes you don't you know
you don't realize what's going on until
you see how it affects real folks
name that movie line people up there but
I'm going to say something here the
death stats that you're getting are
bullcrap now I want to cute manatee to
search this because this is the story
that's going around everywhere in the
morning you guys have heard there
undoubtedly undercounting deaths right
there saying there probably more deaths
than we know about can you bring this up
to acute matter yeah run the search if
you run that search that's in there
Kovac deaths underreported let's just
type in that COBIT deaths under report I
don't run the search this morning yep
okay there you go nothing but articles
about how it is underreported how there
are more deaths than we know here are a
couple of things that we need to keep in
mind okay I mean everyone knows this the
original production was 2.5 million yeah
ok then thought you just admitted that
the projection of a hundred and two
hundred forty thousand wasn't over
estimate and now it's about sixty
thousand now keep in mind some people
are arguing well that's because the
social distancing no no the estimate was
a hundred to two hundred forty thousand
taking into account social distancing
that that would reduce it to that number
and keep in mind that a huge portion of
the social distancing wasn't supposed to
have an impact yet
yeah what's supposed to kick in because
there were a lot of people who were
carriers or who were asymptomatic for it
so you cannot have it both ways that's
important to note here's something else
while we're talking about this and we
said but you should really trust the
medical advisors don't trust Donald
Trump well as we're talking about as it
turns out the actual death rate let's go
to doctor dr. Brooks can you talk about
your concerns about deaths being this
reported
because either testing for standards or
how they're characterized so I think in
this country we've taken a very liberal
approach to mortality that's on a face
mask she wasn't scarf like a style
statement good job it's the cat it's the
exact handkerchief we put on Betty after
she gets pays so it's like she's a pink
handkerchief she doesn't shield you from
microbes it could please one on TV so
really quickly to just a couple stats
that we'll set something up because I
lost sleep over this last night I
stumbled across something that I'm
amazed has not been reported on so New
York they said they would need remember
about 30,000 ventilators yeah
remember Donald Trump got so much crap
you can guys you guys don't have to be
statues this isn't Madame Tussauds are
you already drunk given 30,000
ventilators remember this and Donald I
don't know what to do with the
ventilators we need to look into that
and how could there he say that
well they peaked at needing only a
fraction what they thought at 4,000 Wow
they've never needed 30,000 ventilators
or certainly they haven't reached that
peak yet something else that is
important okay I this is how it kind of
started last night I was looking at
going well people who have the flu must
be compromised right so how many people
are dying just from the flu and I
noticed we can have this overlay right
here this is the CDC image that flu
deaths and pneumonia they've gone down
to effectively zero hmm oh that's weird
we checked in at the Cecily decades yeah
no one's getting the flu this year right
no you're just saying I wanted to assume
as usual that I'm wrong but reg our
researcher is very smart and so if I say
anything yes Steven you are wrong when
I'm scared like I've discovered
something like I have this I have this
phobia and it's because when I was a kid
and I went to summer camp and they had a
prize for someone who invents something
and you said like we make it out of pipe
cleaners and what I did was I made I
made a dog feeder where the dog pushes a
button and the pipe cleaner pushes open
a cereal box and it feeds him and then
I'm good well no
they said it wasn't Honey I Shrunk the
kids and I realize oh yeah it is so I
didn't find always assumed that I'm
wrong if I have the inside lane on
something so I look I'm like well zero I
said okay well maybe what's happening is
just well no that doesn't make sense
because more people will be tested for
the flu going in ready for being tested
for bid you would think more people are
being test and maybe because of the
social distancing can yeah more people
are being tested for the flu yes so many
most people who were going in for Cova
testing aren't actually getting tested
for kovat because they're reserving the
test for the people who are higher risk
right showing severe symptoms but they
have enough flu tests so all of those
people are being tested for the flu so
yes 100% we're driving more flu tests
right so the flu death rate is very low
we're testing for the flu well okay so
you just cut me off at the pass because
I was I wasn't able to advocate with
myself but my actual advocate yes was
the devil he's going to be an altar
woman in Canada right yeah another
excellent but you know a little inside a
little inside baseball for those who
have join us in the morning I know how
wrong Stephen is when he pitches
something to reg by how long reg says
you know red just thinking like right
huge idiot and I like Lee you know
there's a good chance but I the one
thing I do all surround myself with
geniuses so you'll never know go because
I'm an idiot with self-awareness so it'd
be like if Rain Man I'm mentally
[ __ ] so I check with people okay no
flu deaths that's where it's same thing
with pneumonia
I said maybe fewer people are getting
tested no more people are getting tested
and keep in mind to also 7 to 15 percent
of all flu deaths every year are some
form of corn a virus not this novel
coronavirus but some form of coronavirus
that's why your Lysol and you're right
max is a hit right as hay it kills
coronavirus with
17,000 deaths recorded from coronavirus
okay
so what this is telling us right now is
that all of those flu deaths all of
those pneumonia deaths right those are
they're all being counted as coronavirus
so that's important to know everything's
gonna be everything is being counted
coronaviruses even if they have these
other conditions and i thought well okay
that's not really fair because that's
not the standard that we use in
measuring deaths for anything else for
example if someone has the flu when they
also going undergoing a chemo treatment
right recount cancer is a leading cause
of death so right away that's tipping
the numbers a little bit but then it
gets worse here's what I went to the CDC
website after I saw that chart and on
the flu death thing is weird this is how
they're counting deaths a lot of people
are saying well they're just they're
counting deaths almost even they want to
be liberal as bricks not bricks that's
Hans Brix Burke's just said this is from
the CDC bring this up to keep Matt your
people will think I'm lying in cases
where a definite diagnosis of kovat 19
cannot be made but it is suspected or
likely compelling within a reasonable
degree of certainty it is acceptable to
report kovat 19 under death certificate
as probable or presumed in these
instances instances certifiers should
use their best clinical judgment in
determining if a kovat 19 infection was
likely mm-hmm
so not only I'm just gonna say not yeah
just guess what yes just yes usually not
only are they lumping in so awesome go
look at the charts flu deaths boom
nothing
pneumonia just boom nothing now all Cova
deaths not only are they all being
registered as kovin 19 deaths but
doctors can also there you go that was a
chart from earlier the flus dropping
down but they can also make a guess that
well we assumed that person died from
Kovan reading this is important for two
reasons science is flawless the
scientific method is flawless human
beings applying it our are not do you
not think for a second that some leftist
activists who also happens to work in a
hospital in New York is not going to
take every single opportunity possible
to try and label this AK Ovid 19 death
if they are not required to actually
show any proof of a positive test just
think of what the media does with this
or even even somebody who's one more
thing and then I wanted one more thing
this this is what's crazy about it
because you go how can these models be
so wrong
and maybe someone out there can totally
correct me on this everything I've said
here is just taken directly from the CDC
website they don't apply this same
standard to infection rates so they
cannot assume that someone has Co vid 19
unless they test positive and we now
know according to the CDC 20 something
percent of people are asymptomatic
eighty percent of people have very mild
symptoms so we cannot say oh that person
didn't test we didn't run a test but
we're pretty sure they have Kovac
because right now they're running all
the flu tests right they are actually
trying to eliminate possibilities so
they can guesstimate I hate that word
but I'm using it because I want to piss
people off I get that it's redundant
estimate is to make a guess what's
guesstimate to make a [ __ ] we get it
it's the same exact double guess if he
likes if you like me saying redundant
it's recom dumb recumbents dumb bint
what you laying down I'm just saying
it's just redundant times two we are
saying a co vid 19 deaths you can guess
but you cannot guess you have to have
proof of infection rent what do you
think that does to the mortality rate
not the overall deaths far fewer they're
saying deaths are being underreported no
no no no no no no infections are being
underreported for all we know we could
have two three four ten times the amount
of people right now out there with kovat
19 we cannot guess we cannot estimate
but we can throw out numbers if we think
within a reasonable I guess sort of
barometer of suspicion that they could
have had covin 19 we list it as a CO vid
19 death so what can that do that can
take a mortality rate from 0.2% 0.4% to
3% or 5% and it's important to note
that's what the models were based on
that's what the 2.5 million came from
and in the 100,000 to 240,000 so you can
talk about social distancing all you
want and that is true you should be
taking your precautions wear your masks
which we said before they said you
should wear masks I said I bet they're
going to come out and say we're masks
nostradamus here apparently a comic in a
bathrobe but this is incredible that the
models are based on this this is what
happens when you don't have an Asian
doing your math right in an Asian would
know this wholly
holy crap one sec look at look at Gibbon
Wow get right up turns out bill Wow I
told you guys I'm only agent from the
waist of the neck do you get more read
does it increase or like a rate limiting
factor now it'll keep happening I'm
gonna get pretty splotchy all over my
body
okay all right
well give him another drink if I can use
another beer okay so I'm just gonna
drink something to go he couldn't talk
I'm Cameron I was like bartender Oh
something else that I need to add here
um we've had 17,000 deaths reported from
makovan 19 right a bad flu two years ago
was 61,000 so right now if you total up
flu deaths from this year which drop
down to zero when he had this co-ed
pandemic 39 a total of 39,000 if you add
up Kovac and flu bad flu year was 61
thousand so if you add up all of the flu
deaths right now all of the pneumonia
deaths all of the Cova 19 deaths it is
still not as high as a slightly severe
flu season now I'm not saying I won't
get higher than that but we don't not
saying it's comfortable to the flu as
far as how easy it can be transmitted by
us we don't shut down the entire economy
for that number not even close and this
is with the books being cooked and you
correct me if you think I'm wrong I
think if you are allowed to guess if you
lump all deaths under Kovac 19
regardless of what other comorbidities
are there and then you're allowed to
guess and say let's chalk it up as kobe
19 but you cannot do it with the actual
infections I think that's dishonest in
the American people should know they
should why is it considered journalistic
malpractice to let the American public
in on positive news right I have no idea
and I think the whole point to this is
that we're all willing to make a
sacrifice we're all willing to do what
we need to do to stop some kind of
threat but the response needs to be in
proportion to the threat and right now
we don't understand the threat and so
when you come at me with two and a half
million deaths early on that means if
you extrapolate it out about a hundred
million people in this country of 360
ish million three fifty whatever it is
are going to get this
virus were in China even if they were
lying by a factor of 10 they had a
million yeah you're telling me we're
gonna have a hundred times what China
had right in two and a half million I'm
gonna die none of it made any sense but
that's the number that we use to say oh
god we have to close up writing down
numbers that they use right now or go
down to 200 but you know what I think I
think if you actually if you actually
want to know the number of people who
are young and I don't even mean under 50
and relatively healthy these people
could still be overweight by the way I'm
not talking about the event there's a
lot of people who don't have severe
conditions already if you want to know
the total number of people who will die
from kovat with that we're already well
past that number the number now the
total deaths is actually significantly
higher than I think we will ever reach
as far as young healthy people now again
what did we do on this program we said
it could get really bad but there's some
there's some politics at play then I had
my doctor on dr. Choi's groin we talked
about it told people what precautions
they could take we've tried to be as
clear as possible and I do think that a
lot of this not not the fact the virus
is not a hoax of course not because I'm
not saying that at all but the political
fallout we will look back at this as one
of the greatest shams perpetrating the
American public yeah with some of the
most dire consequences closing down the
economy like this it takes time to come
back right yeah I'm gonna level with you
it's usually freezing cold in the studio
but I'm about to take off every no
that's totally fine wait blotches are we
allowed we see the blockage can you
check let's check you don't have to be
on camera we do need to check the
blotches right no on a glass Jack well
you check it but you know what while
you're doing that you check it let's uh
I believe we have a Thomas Finnegan
don't we with the traffic report oh okay
we know that many of you of course your
morning routines have been affected and
so we are here to serve you
time for traffic report with Thomas
Finnegan
[Music]
all right mr. Finnegan are you there sir
I am here even good thank you you're
staying safe please update us on what
people can expect in their morning
commute well your commute from all
directions mm-hmm what just happened was
what just happened there Thomas Finnegan
we're not hearing once you're in the
kitchen center be on the lookout for
some emergency responders okay who are
cleaning up an earlier incident
involving a microwave and aluminium foil
aluminum Oh
aluminium yeah I didn't know that our
reporter was Canadian okay great is
there anything by the way we can hear
you no see my nipples we can hear
everything you're saying
at 9:24 central aah Finnegan anything
else we need to know about nothing else
Raven you're good are you in the ice
your toilet flushing sir are you in the
bathroom really maybe okay
[Music]
oh right I think you get a dead spot you
lost are you watching do you know if
you're splotchy this is two drinks in
two drinks or did you get hit with a
blow dart somebody dragged him from the
ceiling people let's go let us know if
the mother saying that can you guys see
the step get it get up to the camera
here showed off actually
you know it's just taking sir headphones
okay and come over here so people can
see so this so this is for contrast this
is pretty red right that's my that's my
purple but come over here come right
here given so people can yeah let me see
your face right here oh my oh my god no
no his face is red it is wait my god
this isn't an ice bath you look like
hell boy yeah actually look a little bit
like hell yeah it's keep sittin bull'
over here no I think we've proven our
point Red Skull here needs some crackers
wanna go back out there and sit in the
the yogibo and take a breather no no
leave him here you know so this happened
to me I was thrown in the story the 7 of
me in college when I found out that this
happened I was at a party and I was
drinking a beer I had about half a beer
and someone comes up to me and they go
are you ok of course I'm ok it was about
the sixth or seventh person that came up
to me and said are you ok and put their
hand on my shoulder that I went to the
bathroom and said oh my god what the
heck happen is made ya something else it
happens too when he gets drunk he gets
that I'm noticing you get more you get
less articulate but very chatty
yeah very quiet most of the time I was
Italian for like nine months I know I do
we know what this is the Asian rotation
because I remember I had a psychiatrist
who told me she's like it's a genetic
it's an enzyme thing it is it's an
enzyme thing so kind of like lactose
intolerance okay yeah though people are
missing that enzyme that helps them
digest like
and Asian cultures we definitely you
know we usually don't drink milk okay
lactose intolerance - I'm actually
pretty good with lactose intolerant I am
less doesn't tell you are like oh yeah
how do you do with bats hmm delicious is
here look I like that gumbo incredibly
sick I wouldn't mind that audio way we
having heard from you this morning what
do you think about dead do you think
he's safe in here we need an update I
hope so it does look like his foreheads
about to pop our peanut butter and I was
on the toilet just trying to let it go
yeah it's not feeling well you know when
you get you some water let us know well
if he does die it'll be contributed as a
cove at 19 death we're heading to those
deaths hey and by the way please do hit
the notification bell if you were
subscribed and if you haven't joined my
club yet a lot of credit calm slash mug
Club Crowder bits is another YouTube
channel of the iTunes podcast so
something else I wanted to talk about
this is making the rounds quite a bit
and the the hydroxychloroquine thing so
remember we were on this really early
yeah to the point where when we titled
our YouTube video about chloroquine I
remember that we kind of go through a
title process we go okay we want to make
sure that people can search it and find
it sexual assault is not a good nervous
tender it's far more severe than a word
with a wee Herman
some people say ah and I just go nervous
tick should be legal
y'all are gonna think I'm a bad lawyer
okay what's wrong with him he's nervous
that's more proactive than a tic you got
spreadsheets so the Trump chloroquine
think we actually member we said well we
don't want to title it chloroquine right
guys right
people don't oh wait hold on a second we
should check in with CNN a little bit
let's see every continent except
Antarctica on petabyte Cove in nineteen
correlations all we need to know cold
kills it it's time to move this is CNN
we didn't know how to tell it because we
said most people know chloroquine so
let's see if we can title jaraguá and
now this has become the number one cause
is to attack Donald Trump chloroquine
this has become the cause this becomes
out of the lose unit right now it's
unbelievable and when you actually look
at it I think the big reason why man you
can bring up that overlay I think the
reason why is because he's right they
tend not to like that when you have they
go oh there's zero scientific evidence
well there's actually quite a bit of
evidence many hundreds of people we've
seen different we've seen a variance in
the rates of efficacy in these different
sort of Konoe you're not double-blind
clinical trials but they're about as
good as you can get they already
approved drug that can be prescribed
off-label and now over six thousand
doctors signed a petition six thousand
doctors signed on saying this was the
drug that they actually supported it's
being used in hospitals across the
country don't you just love that
Michigan and I think Nevada put AB and
they said we're not going to give that
to our people and they should sorry what
I meant the opposite ship as much of it
as he can oh never mind
you know what you read these articles
that are attacking the [ __ ] they're
like oh I can't believe you would tout
this terrible truck you're not a doctor
Trump you're not a doctor news person
who's reporting it but the Trump and the
news outlets that are reporting on the
effective treatment are always reporting
about doctors right yeah the reporters
are getting are from Trump's briefed all
over the country who are saying hey I'm
not saying it it works of everyone and
it certainly their individual right
which it will be ineffective but we are
doing it and the evidence that we see
the empirical evidence is it's working
right and what's crazy is they watch us
CNN and I hate
I do it but I'm doing this for you
please do join my club otherwise reload
and then I don't want it can't be a
Walter because I can't get in trouble my
sponsor but if I kill me too much CNN it
will be a competitors firearm yes
definitely well but I have a question I
the Walter but no I do what go ahead
what's our standard for information
right now because you know and people
are giving him a hard time for saying
there's hold on let me let me play this
out they're giving him a hard time for
saying there's a possibility that this
could be beneficial let's look at it we
get numbers all the time that started
out at two and a half million deaths two
hundred forty thousand deaths down it's
like and we're like oh no that's good
we're we're fine taking that kind of
variance but Donald Trump says it might
be a helpful thing to use and rights
that's a great there's are less variance
in all of the trials or studies no
there's far less variance out there for
chloroquine and there is variance in the
death rates yeah what's funny is when
they report on it a watch CNN and
they'll say Oh dr. Trump sorry Trump as
Moses just a random guy I'll give you an
update yeah I have so my body has
metabolize the alcohol I am drunk I am
moving into the hungover phase if
already Barrett can get me a tour please
look we have young Dolph Lundgren on the
screen on CNN I want to see Universal
Soldier four will go on there and I saw
this I think it was yesterday saying
Donald Trump ignoring the advice of you
know medical professionals who now
predict the death rate 60,000 and then
they show clip from doctor voci that's
his advisor yeah he's the one who had
him out there to press Congress you
didn't get a scoop Erin Burnett
you just didn't run the press briefing
and then you talk about it like the
death rates that are coming out are
coming out from Donald Trump and his
cabinet and his advisors from anywhere
else it's unbelievable to me
so they've been going after
hydroxychloroquine and this can't happen
with the Young Turks and on CNN now the
attack is why is Donald Trump so Pro
hydroxychloroquine because it works no
because he stands to make money
that's right let's go through that
really quickly man so they talk about
this as an article from Daily Beast how
he owned stock
in a company that may be making
chloroquine tablets when you run the
numbers I want to make sure I get this
right he only owes between he owns
between 99 and a thousand four hundred
eighty five dollars of that stock in
stock he's a billionaire so you know
what this company is - right if he if he
found that in his pocket it would be
less than you finding a twenty yeah it's
part of it it's part of a mutual fund I
think red yes invested him in our mutual
funds we have no idea here's here's the
thing anyone out there who's gonna
criticize him for being invested in one
of the largest French manufacturers of
pharmaceuticals Santa Fe every one of
you who has a mutual fund
you're probably in it as well right so
Michael Moore is probably in it oh
definitely he hates him so he's okay
yeah it's it's unreal to me compare that
by what we're talking about a vested
interest so you can say Oh a conflict of
interest what is a president not
supposed to have any sort of diversified
portfolio no mutual funds you can just
come right on it don't worry about it
just come on no distracting for a creepy
Colombian Tulum by the door you want
some - I can take another Clif Bar okay
I've noticed that the others oh my god
there's an angry lesbian who I'm not
what is that unser no no that's Daniel
reckless you ask him a question in like
it takes him five seconds yeah answers
now there's like a delay while we're
talking about vested interests she what
does she have
it'll be okay poor poor little Betty hey
how are we gonna keep this show going if
she's that role of gaff tape we show
together
how would anything how would we get
she's wearing a dress she isn't a dress
poor dog in the office hit my wife
because I can't gonna dress your dog is
a lady dog yes lady I don't know hair
that disgusts me interest in a mutual
fund 99 to a thousand dollars compare
that to the vested interest that that
New York Times has right when you look
at what the money that's exchanged hands
with Democratic donors when you look at
people who have actually worked in
administrations that are either now
reporters or have been op-ed journalists
at the New York Times when you I mean
Paul Krugman you just look at any of
these people at the New York Times not
to mention remember their probability
that the probability numbers that they
hand at the election it was 99 point
something percent that Hillary election
and like we've said just like with Cove
in nineteen and obviously there are
facts do exist we need to be clear about
that right but you can also try and
manipulate them to change public
behavior but that's what happened with
the election they were hoping that
people would just feel completely
depressed completely devastated that
they wouldn't have any fight in them and
come out and vote for Donald Trump so
they're 99 percent that night we were
streaming and I remember Gerald started
drinking before the show and said well
Hillary Clinton's gonna win tonight so
let's just this is gonna be a rough
night and then it was the best night
ever just because the young turks
meltdown okay just wait until michigan
comes in that was one of my best nights
we'll send you a walter but it was
remarkable and they did this because
they wanted people to basically wanted
it to be a self-fulfilling prophecy
that's what's happening right now with
some of the co vid 19 death so new york
times has a far worse the company can't
this is if you're going to talk about
big pharma okay well we're talking about
chloroquine this is how you know that
someone actually cares okay Donald Trump
could probably get some serious
kickbacks what right now his hotels
can't be a bit receive any bailout no
just so you know he's signed on that
wasn't even an issue wasn't even argued
right what are you what are you saying
that no public officially what what you
let me know at forty minutes forty yeah
is making symbols we've never used these
symbols doing gay for signals what are
you using he does assisting you he's
doing it like he's let me in like look
he's giving me like a hot tip at the
greyhound trail let you run distance
he's like the third-base coach oh
they're like signaling you what is this
a drug deal going on so if you were to
have some conspiracy about a drug you
could have created a much better when
Donald Trump is not receiving any money
into his hotel so that's not really
conspiracy as far as drugs chloroquine
is generic there's no patent on it no
anybody can make it it's been around
since the 1940s it's being made by a ton
of other companies as far as I
understand it even bear who make aspirin
yeah or at least they they said that
they could I don't know if they're
actually going to be doing it so many
companies are so if Donald Trump wanted
to get a kickback on a drug you know
what he would do he would pick a company
that has exclusive rights he's the
president the United States right if you
see some kind of a Republican senator
from whatever it is Omaha can engage in
insider trading you don't think that
Donald Trump can make a call to Pfizer
and buy up a few mutual funds I know
anything about finances and I just write
it off yeah so for the death rates
they're guessing at the top number of
the fraction and the bottom number of
the fraction right they're reporting all
their guesses but if you know that Trump
can only make like a hundred bucks from
this whole thing you got you not going
to report that number know anything else
but so I think there's two points here
one is for yourselves right every time
you have a news story come on it needs
to be about Donald Trump his handling of
this and how bad it is right right the
thing that we saw with the cry on or
whatever it is at the bottom that said
every something ran track I run every
one
thank you I always do it back easy from
a drunk Asian herd chyron crayon right
yeah it's not true that was unacceptable
you can even pause for that one jerk oh
so it said you know every continent on
the planet has been affected yes thank
you that means that potentially seven
countries have been in fact to notice an
article and the Penguins are safe other
than them I know but what I'm saying is
like they're making up these out as
rocky as possible I'm just gonna keep
talking as bad as possible and then they
won't report anything on Donald Trump
when he when he owns something that's a
thousand dollars like you said it's a
rounding error to him you're just gonna
say something general about it you're
trying to make it look as bad as
possible for him and for the virus right
and not reporting any good news at all
no exactly by the way we've gone through
the clinical debt this is important to
note we've had clinical studies where
they haven't had they haven't been
controlled because if someone actually
has severe khova dried they don't want
to run the risk of receiving a placebo
so that's not a hard to do but we have
studied pretty big we have pretty big
sample sizes in multiple different
instances now in people and it does seem
to consistently be working again
thousands of doctors have signed on
saying this is actually something that
we want to use it was by far and away
there was a poll the most effective
treatment when doctors were polled so
not even people who proactively signed
on to say this needs to be a part of the
protocol then when they were asked
doctor said yeah hydroxychloroquine with
the z-pak his most effective number two
was chloroquine by itself number three
was nothing and then everything else was
after nothing so we want to be clear
about that then they also did study it
in vitro like in a petri dish where they
think they found the mecca that sort of
novel mechanism of action as to why it
might work and it may not be the
antiviral capabilities it actually may
be some kind of mediation of the
inflammatory response specifically as it
relates to the immune system so I'm
really nerdy these things are all very
interesting but the point is we have
examples and humans that it works and we
think we understand scientifically at
least as to why it works then
anecdotally this lady of color person of
color puck from Michigan Darren Whitsett
she credits chloroquine and Trump with
saving her life and she really really
didn't want to say that by the way and
I'm not sure if that's the lady or I'm
just confusing it with another black
lady from Michigan who was in the
legislature I think that's
when we were doing the I'm just a bill
the transgender parody came up to the
Capitol building and said yeah y'all
doin y'all do this class Rock took a
picture and uploaded it to Instagram and
then was very cross yes when she found
out what the video was and then
basically removed it may have been
caring what set probably not I don't
know how you doing there uh given I yeah
I'm in the hungover phase I'm drinking a
lot you're actually hungover already yes
already I have I have a pendant we hired
I feel terrible but I'm going to I'm
gonna stay the course okay say the
course look so bad now when you're under
the right light of course you can't
always depend on that light but little
splotchy little splotchy yeah I say a
little sparse yeah you look like you
should be at a kids party in the
McDonald's playpen grimace you are
purple you are more purple than my
purple by the way again we mentioned
Crowder bits the podcast oh wait hold on
a second actually I think we have to go
to right now of course in says the
morning to breaking news yeah
[Music]
for breaking news while Ruth Crowder on
Parham elephant based on previous
projections that have been subject to
chains and now can be verified the CBC
has officially and this can be held
legally accountable change their coded
estimate of deaths Phil for will keep
you abreast as this story unfold for
bringing those outer walls crawler
I'm sorry ma
[Applause]
I had a I'm radio flashbacks they're
like driving in my dad's car and yeah
some grainy a.m. talk-show person yeah
Perry's been around for a while he's
been around for a long high level for a
while got us into a lot of hot water did
ever take about that when we were
because we were out of Detroit we were
broadcasting and what happened is when
this show started for those I don't
think is chat not working today is it
let's forget it doing jet let's see if
we can bring it from check i know chad
is an issue right now you can't give us
your name because the usernames aren't
working i don't know why yeah I'm pissed
about it so earlier yeah earlier you
asked about people who had had the covin
19 if this person Andrew says my dad and
I contracted and fully recovered we lost
our sense of smell and had a bad cough
sorry that might be a little too much as
I can
the nasals I can yeah no do not use that
yeah I've known people who have lost
their senses really why should I really
yeah permanently Wow permanently tell us
more vampires I came as a pill do not
inhale that really yeah you and innate
but the NATO is not inhale you rub it
around your nasal cavity or you talk
about the spray suppress afraid okay
did you use it can you still take I can
still smell everything you know it's
funny you know like this is happening in
real time I just wanted to prove that I
am more Asian than bill baby maybe the
23 you are absolutely more Asian than
bill I'll take my pants off right now
big words for a man who didn't even want
to wear robe come on we're all wearing
pajamas he's a hey I want to wear robe
that's a nice row I still have my suit
check it off sure I know because this is
how he sleeps his suit with the roads to
keep up appearances love as he sits next
to a drunken Asian who's about to throw
up all over this torso is excellent yes
the the hungover phase has passed I'm
now drinking beer again
wonderful plan of action I literally
poisoned my body but I feel as though
I've cleared just enough of it that I'm
at the cusp of recovery let me drink
more drink
you know what's terrible about giving is
like terrible for him I've done is I've
done this bet thing before right really
gullible rooms of white guys where I'm
like well you know I can't drink that
much because I'll get all red in the
face like then you know I've had too
much to drink and then you know like 11
shots later they're on the floor I'm
like alright I'm gonna take that money
again I'll take that money Thanks you do
that again Oh see now he pushed it up
when he fails yeah hey I did not sound
like Gerald when I did no you said like
Richard Simmons napped by his Brazilian
housekeeper home one more chat yeah we
have another another chat anyway we have
somebody says nope safe in Italy don't
know anyone with the China virus it's
Susan in Italy I think that person's
trying a little too hard with
reiterating Italy Italy and idly is like
the war zone well it might not be it
should help actually it's written in an
accent pretty hello I don't know many
dagoes named Susan right maybe she's on
vacation so I do have a story there was
one of my clients who did their group
contracted it they were in Australia it
actually made the news your set up has
become tiresome he's drunk if I keep a
drunk man's interest nothing to offer
no anyway but good notes about your
Aussie drunk awesome so they went down
there to do what my group of 10 people
we're quarantined and they actually
received death threats from Australian
people that thought that they had
brought this virus well that was their
area that's an island of nothing but
felons and raping well pretty much
that's their that's their hair but it's
Alcatraz no tarantula was a British
colony for a penal colony yeah anyway so
they finally did you know make it back
to the United States last night so that
I do know one person at least that had
it yeah how bad was it not bad now that
at all no and I'm not saying that there
are cases where it's bad but if it asked
me because everyone that I've known
who's had it has it's been a cough it's
been a coffin a headache yeah right so
I'm not saying it's Pleasant but
everyone that I know then again most
people who I know who had it are younger
and are healthy younger meaning under
the age of 50 and then right now my
mother who is our wardrobe stylist she
has pneumonia pretty severe so she's
nowhere near here and that is
significantly worse than any of the
coronavirus cases that we've seen yes
and we've seen at least suspected quite
a few and in this instance if we suspect
it we write it as definitely Cove at 19
right because we're following all right
you know what maybe I should tell my
Taco Bell story but before we get to
that and actually you'll be able to
shine on Monday where we doing another
Mass Monday on Monday and that's why
you're able to say audio wait and and
Gerald really know their theology you
know I will say this saying I don't
shine any other time this is a comedy
show let's be honest scrapyard it's not
your strong suit not your right no
that's what you people don't realize
that when you first came on the show
before you were on the show I would ask
you questions about the Bible theology
and sort of Islam yeah because I know
that you taught some of these courses at
churches and I said you know what you've
got a good voice you've got a great
voice for radio you're articulate won it
and come on the show and nobody has
stepped on jokes better than me son well
there were no jokes and just complaints
too from the government of Pakistan on
Twitter that's good Pakistan I've said
this before not a person in Pakistan
violation of Pakistan that's got to make
you feel good entire country a fan of
Pakistanis which remember how much
trouble george w bush got in because i
used the word [ __ ] yeah that didn't used
to be a racist term it was gonna breed
right and now likes a Pakistani what am
I retired I don't have time to say I'm
not drunk sitting over in fourth chair
well we were and I want to go back to
the mast Monday but we were talking
about that like [ __ ] yeah you were
saying that that's never once been
offensive to you now again if someone
says it like fu [ __ ] yeah but I'm
not a [ __ ] intended to be exact where's
the n-word what I think I think people
who focus so much on the words and they
miss the intent are the problem because
right really it doesn't take using a
slur or a semi slur or maybe potentially
hypothetically a slur or something like
that it's all about the intent and what
people are doing and you can't listen to
comedy and not feel a little offended
like literally that is the essence of
comedy itself yeah so knowing that
someone is doing it with an intent to
actually bring people closer together
and the part that I think is the most
hilarious about is most slurs that are
used are actually some basis of the
words that are used between the people
within that race anyways and and so just
hey what do you try knees people call
the Chinese people I can't say it on air
okay I remember when I was so chatty
when he drinks ever heard you speak I
will ask you the question you know this
I will have an idiom because given it
given has now become the the showrunner
he's been doing a great job by the way
absolutely wonderful make sure the
trains running him but I will ask my
question but hey what happened here and
what do you think he'll go hmm that's it
comes back with a reasoned response
whereas right now so don't make any
don't you read before the meetings oh I
was gonna say I should start drinking
before meeting yeah okay you would think
that right now I feel so happy what I
was gonna say went when I was a [ __ ] I
remember my I heard my grandmother say
look like a [ __ ] I'm a right here my
grandmother say
[ __ ] and I remember thinking like oh
grandma that is that's kind of crazy and
she was like Irishman Englishman right
[ __ ] it's the same thing
yeah you're saying the same thing no
one's mental Martin Scorsese right well
some people are but that's mainly
because again
four hours oh my god the directors
unreasonable please does it come with a
cyanide pill and Al Pacino's book of
extensive accents by the way it's one
page it's really just a booklet like do
not rape pants and hand it out in
Germany on New Year's the tri-fold it is
remark yeah Anna man is a good example
like when we're doing the kung-fu
fighting with a censor it now the guy
what's an inbred Douglas look at that so
not only do you have the lyrics of the
entire song so let's take this as an
examination right of context and I was
talking about George Bush saying package
in the context I said you know you have
for example the trade with with pakis
they're not happy with he wasn't at all
then they're getting them he was
actually people of accused of being too
Pro Pakistan so in other words like
invited I was in Montreal that's what
was used all the time
again it wasn't intended to be racist
now it's that abbreviation is more
racist than the lesser abbreviation but
[ __ ] let's take that from kung-fu
fighting because someone was arrested in
the UK for singing kung fu fighting
we've talked about this at a karaoke bar
yeah you can go back to a video we did a
whole thing maybe Maddie can can bring a
source up if you wants to kung fu
fighting arrested now let's see it's
like okay is this a situation with the
absence of absence of context no it's a
black guy in a kung fu uniform who is
doing a song that is literally praising
Chinese culture yeah the entire thing
talk about how much he loves kung-fu
fighting okay so we look at that doesn't
seem like he hates anybody who's Chinese
there it is man representing kung fu
fighting if we didn't bring it up you
would think I'm lying the only reason I
bring up over last attempt I don't want
you to think that I'm lying like see he
goes okay there were funky China men
from funky Chinatown was that they were
chopping around me up they were chopping
around me down yeah it's an ancient
Chinese art and everybody knew their
part knew their part was afirma
something to a kick now we're into a
brand new trick everybody was kung foo
full military did I hear racism yeah
it's a it's a love letter to the Chinese
culture which by the way entirely false
a kung fu fighting doesn't work but he
really like
it's just amazing to me yo look at that
and go is is this did he mean this as a
racist term and it wasn't really
considered racist term at that point now
if he walked up and was like what's your
problem little drunk [ __ ] I'd like
hey mr. Douglas right yeah he's Okinawan
I mean pardon me yeah I did just because
you're drunk and you know I figured I
could say it without getting in trouble
words if I said it to bill he could use
it against me someday yes we'll use it
against you someday I love bill but
lawyer get a lawyer because okay no
one's actually Japanese not Chinese and
there's a there's a thing Gerald a map
and Gerald do you have a pointer I do
here let me look here what happened it
changed my mind where someone was racist
to you yeah there was a kid he was an
Asian kid and he he was talking about
how all white people are terrible and we
should all get cancer and I said to him
I was like you know actually I'm
Japanese and he said oh well you should
have been there when we found you I mean
I don't know that I'm offended but no
I'm not but I do think but it wasn't
very nice it was not yeah not nice to
say well keep eating your practic so
here's something else so we did math
Monday and I say this is an audio wait
and gerald strong suit when we do the
math Mondays now I'm one of those guys
I've read the Bible through like cover
to cover three times they did a one-year
Bible but it doesn't mean that I
retained all of it and then it was what
was that CD series that you had me it
was about the Bible and learn the Bible
in 24 hours more useful than reading
bloody the whole Bible oh yeah and I
realize it was kind of one of those it
wasn't a religious thing I just wanted
to have read the whole Bible but then
unfortunately I forgot
look Jacob's Ladder I can tell you more
about the horror film in the story in
the bottom are so important culturally
it Slayer dream yeah people like Jacobs
ladders or colloquialisms like people
who don't anything about what about
Esther I don't know I just
Jacobs ladders and saying I saw it
CrossFit they have this thing called
Jacob's Ladder it's really hard I get
revved in the house look for some reason
it's given unduly important it really is
yes so you
know this pretty well and we did this on
last Monday we did math Monday on
rhettandlink they're what they call
spiritual deconstruction they left the
photo I don't want to use that term they
basically abandon their face as
Christians and here's one thing that I
want to keep in context here I do things
that I regret all the time people who
say no regrets what like I don't like
when I watch a film and there's a guy in
his deathbed he's like I can say
regretted nothing about what yesterday
audio Wade you were there and I made a
joke cuz I was drinking straight milk
straight from the carton because I'm the
only one who drinks goat's milk at the
house yeah and then I was like oh this
is four days expired I think it was
seven seven yeah on behalf of yourself
and your [ __ ] have some regrets you
will I mean for crying out loud looks
like a bruised peach I feel terrible
you're back to the hungover already
drink water it would take it took 40
seconds you don't have to keep training
up you've proven the point move on we
don't need a geneticist I mean every
time the camera goes away I whisper to
him keep drinking the bad angel be clear
we I've done some things that I'm not
proud of in my life I've gotten things
wrong I of course have regrets but when
it came to addressing the rhettandlink
podcast where they effectively are
trying to drive thousands of young
people away from Christ that's really
what they're doing I was a Christian I
think that's I don't think that's a good
thing we took as much care as we
possibly it's about as nice of a show as
we was it was yeah it really was and
this was the response from rhettandlink
this is the change my mind meme and
that's steven crowder or as i like to
call him Steven pieces Crowder
he's a podcaster at TCU who sat outside
with a sign that said male privilege is
a myth change my mind and a meme is used
to convey strong hot takes on topics
that are actually important or
completely unimportant
okay let's see a few examples okay uh
Wow
so we don't but you don't need to
believe a Steven piece-of-shit Crowder
far be it for me to argue by the way all
right may like my I want to be clear
my primary issue here is not with being
called a piece of [ __ ] yes I am a little
bit upset because I think it's a
wonderful insult and now I can't use it
because this angry lesbian producer use
it now is an insult I still use it as
you know something about it that I use a
lot excellent it's excellent because
it's like you're not even give him the
credit of being the entire evacuation no
you're in my phone as Steven piece of
[ __ ] really - yeah the curlicue this is
what no no but it's so real right
I didn't ID breckel after everyone home
right now was like you know I never
called it a curlicue but I know will
tell you this story because it's
absolutely true when I was a kid I was I
don't remember many things from before
three years old but I was 2 years not a
lot of Hills I'm just telling given I
drank it like I should have permanent
liver damage because I drank an entire
bottle of Tylenol twice because I was an
idiot I was a kid that was to my brother
my mom was we had cold so she's giving
us like the children's Tylenol right
right and so she's like ok but the lady
would eat a spoonful yeah the liquid and
she goes ok Jordan here's yours and she
turns back and I went and my stomach my
brother being the little pissant that he
was they put steam they put stickers on
like when they I don't know what that is
it's not how they pump you but they have
less stickers you know et when he's in
the fridge so that stickers I mean one
that a smiley face
my brother try to steal it for a
scrapbook they pull the sticker off of
me anyway
I did a lot of things that when I was a
kid but I do remember you know I used to
take when I was two and when I would
have been two and brother might have
been yet four we would take baths
together and so my mom takes my brother
out of the bath she's toweling him off
I'm like mom I gotta go to the bathroom
sorry I don't know if I should not tell
this I think it's ok to do limitations
on child abuse is over and so she's
telling off her my brother and I
remember going like like kind of you
know doing this like I've got it I've
got it she's like just wait and the
booty dance yes and so I did I put it
and it had the curlicue and it was very
sharp I don't know if you know this but
when you've pulled the plug you know
there's there's a current yes and so
whatever's in the bathtub starts going
around so I'm standing there while she's
telling off my brother and I can see the
pointy poof coming around and I'm
picturing like a score I never looks
like a Scorpion's tail
mom because I thought I was gonna get
stabbed by my own excrement Kirlian
scary
I remember that clear as day Oh ladies
and gentlemen you now see what has cost
even if a scorpion you today that's what
you will remember afraid of his own food
and that was the most frustrating point
with this going back to the story it's
like we we did really did I was afraid
of my poop no no I disappoints you know
none of this is a smart segue use that
term but we've been over backwards to to
be kind and if you listen to our entire
you know kind of discussion you you
understood that one we were first and
foremost concern for them like hey man
we're really sorry we said we love the
least you're more than welcome to come
on the show we would love to speak with
retinol yeah exactly and I read some
comments that said you know Steven must
have been triggered because he sounded
you know all the in and you know blah
blah blah I was like triggered what are
you talking about one we don't do that
anyway right but - yeah I'm great at
like good ethical morning yes where the
where the okay anyway I am actually
curbing any instinct that I have
to be as an extra loving as possible
yeah did you see that clip it was it was
pretty bad homonym is like it's just
it's not nothing personal it's what I do
I was pissed off that they actually
whited out the sign I mean which changed
my mind was it I do I need to know no
but the point is they said it so well
there's one of them that he did you
don't want to know what gummy worm is
best and then and then we do have to get
going and we do have to do hook
given up to an IV yeah he needs some
help medical attention is coming don't
worry right is that it first off they're
all they're really concern about being
brand safe yes not sure if calling
someone a piece of [ __ ] his brand say
put maybe on YouTube its brand safe as
long as you do it with the right people
as we've been specifically told nothing
that involves piece of [ __ ] not ever be
monetized or advertiser for like I said
that's been very clear yes no uncertain
terms like yeah you know when you say
like Don Lemon or even the who what a
piece of [ __ ] like that's not gonna be
advertiser Bailey's brad friend brand
friendly as long as you know you're
eating that you're eating pancakes with
the faux hawk right as well trending
page right yes so call me that that's
absolutely fine I don't have any problem
with that I want to be crystal clear but
the brand safe thing that's not gonna
talk about a mass Monday that's not of
value it's not a principle it's not a
virtue and it's the same argument that
they use to make the case that all
churches will be allowing gay marriage
because otherwise they'll die no right
there's a popularity that's one of the
intellectual fallacies that you learn
about in logic 101 and something else
that's very interesting maybe they think
it's more maybe they don't want to be on
brand safe so I commented on the video
right and I here's the thing I want to
be clear I'm not a guy who does the
YouTube drama thing we avoid it like my
own my rule is this try to only punch up
and then if we call someone out we offer
them some kind of recourse in other
words we're not going to debate or have
any one of the shows whose won't really
because because you're an egg it's
because you're an egg on Twitter I have
no interest or you know you get a
fracture like we can't do with everyone
but if I call out for example if
Samantha B says hey I'm tired of it we
will have her on tomorrow yes f Myers
tomorrow
anyone from The Young Turks tomorrow Vox
tomorrow that's the rule so
my man came out of your mouth there at
rhettandlink
the to Steven piece-of-shit Crowder
underneath the video I want to make sure
that I'm quoting directly but I can't
because they hit the comments which I'll
get to it was ha ha ha ha ha ha that was
a comment and then after that so we can
bring this up right here I think we have
a screen recording we don't need the
audio you just use it as b-roll then I
realized that um none of the comments
are showing up now here's the thing
that's kind of and we use expressvpn by
the way go to expressvpn that comes
flash crowd or you get a discount
they're wonderful we did the same thing
with the tulsi gabbard situation if you
go and use an express VPN and go serve
an incognito mode the comments don't
show up so when you leave a comment on
someone's channel and they hide it you
don't see it from your profile yours
will always show up so they'll go oh I
guess it's still there then when we use
expressvpn look now it's gone
and even responding to people saying hey
you know what this is kind of weird that
that you do this was Steven like he
actually seems pretty respectful and I
said hey you know just so you know I
actually grew up with rhett and Link on
YouTube I'm a fan I would love to have
them on the show just because we
disagree on the premise ease of theology
philosophy does not mean that we can't
respectfully disagree and have civil
dialogue right those comments were
hidden so to me that's that's and I
don't think this is an ad hominem that's
hit-and-run cowardice when you and you
have a bigger 16 million subscribers
obviously a bigger channel when we rebut
points and we use biblical verses and we
were but it's theological E and said
what we think that this is actually
incorrect and we would love to talk
about this if they want to otherwise
we're going to continue doing math
Mondays which we do behind the paywall
doing mug club every single week this
isn't something new that was exclusive
to rhett and Link they shouldn't feel
that special and then they respond with
ha ha what a piece of [ __ ] on a channel
with four times the subscribers and then
hide comments that are civil and
respectful that means that that is
cowardly and not only that that also
tells you that there's no interest in a
dialogue when they said when rhett and
Link said we really hope that is coming
I'm talking about our deconstruction
encourages discourse or dialogue well
hold a second what kind of discourse or
dialogue do you mean a group of
Christian people saying that they love
you when they wish the best for you and
that they disagree with you and hope
that maybe you might look
to some of these arguments and do some
research and see why there's validity to
it and then say we respectfully invite
you on to the show we would love to talk
about it as brothers in the Lord in the
spirit of love then you call them a
piece of [ __ ] and they say ha ha that's
kind of funny I would still gladly
respectfully host you on the show hide
delete what kind of discourse were you
looking for you have no interest in
discourse you only have interests and
Pat's on the back because you're cowards
it is cowardly to do that you will never
hear me on this show call someone out
like Sanjay Gupta guy looks weird don't
like him not even sure he's a doctor
John King looks like a bobble head with
a neck that's broken ok on the show he
just been the dashboard and he'd be
going whack whack any Falls that's it
you don't Bob if he wanted to come on
the show I would I would have to be held
account the book of judgment did you in
fact say that I did say that
yeah that sounds accurate because I'm a
piece of [ __ ] you heard rhett and Link
you know that is a parting shot now my
point is there's no interest in dialogue
people say this is like what would you
have to do what would you have to do
beyond that it actually engage in a
conversation of ideas there's nothing I
can think they don't want to say
anything I mean that's the long short of
it is that if they it doesn't help their
narrative to just say hey everyone who's
following us don't go listen to this
this guy's terrible he's right no
opinions because they can't actually
address the opinions themselves they
can't address the points of the
arguments and the verses in the
scripture that were brought up and
during that rebuttal and if their
position was so strong they would have
been ready to be able to do it but they
weren't ready for those types of
arguments that attack their position
right so the only thing they have is
well and even even if they didn't see
the mass Monday even if they were just
responding to you as some kind of cult
as the cultural figure yeah then they're
only the only argument that she made if
if it wasn't argument was he sat outside
of TCU with a sign that said male
privileges of myth I mean come on yeah
right yeah exactly so if is that the
argument that you're a piece of [ __ ] I
don't think so I don't think for the
rape culture is a myth but that you
remember it but by the way do you know
how I know real culture is a myth
because I'm informed by a Christian
worldview and also the history of
Western civilization which was founded
on Christian principles unlike Islamic
societies or Buddhist societies or
palaces take your pick I have learned
about
I don't anything about it well that is
Taoism it seems like I'm made of it's
made up is it made up it's a religion at
sea I guess so none and we would give
them an opportunity hey guys if you
disagree with what your producer said
you have every opportunity to correct
the record you have every opportunity to
say hey we don't really think steven
crowder is a piece of [ __ ] she said that
and she should write floors yours guys
reporting producer gonna angry lesbian
producer right and we would we would
understand right yeah sure I understand
it I wouldn't even expect you to come to
my defense no I wouldn't come to my
defense that's not my issue no Mike you
know is throwing out parting shot I want
to be very clear this is not ad hominem
this isn't making fun of just an
appearance this is a this is a shot over
the bow at your character that's
cowardly it is cowardly to do that and
then not allow any recourse okay this is
these are the ABCs of me we don't do
that on this show and I get it you don't
have to debate any single person who
asks you to you have 60 million
subscribers we don't do that but if my
name left your lips it's cowardly to do
a parting shot and then delete any
record of someone responding especially
and I think by the way especially when
it's respectful if we weren't respectful
if we were responding in kind they
probably left it up and said see I think
the fact that we were saying hey I I
don't have harbor any ill will I can't
even show you the comments because it
disappeared but I would love to
respectfully host them on the show that
actually makes them more inclined I
think that rhettandlink we're gonna do
this on Monday another Mass Monday and I
want to be clear rhett and Link III when
I came up in YouTube like I've been on
YouTube since 2007 they started early on
first mover's I respect them with that
but I do think that rhett and Link are
going to be surprised as to how much
they come out of this the bad guy
because I know I'm like this super
villain the Vox ad pocalypse where
YouTube ad the changes policy and I say
naughty words and rhett and Link our
brand safe but I think people can smell
it on you when they sense cowardice when
they sense bullying and by the way 16
million channel responding viciously to
a respectful rebuttal that's bullying
you guys are bullies I don't know how
that works into your deconstruction
because you thought the Christians
weren't empathetic but you're bullies
your cowardly bullies and I would love
to hash this we don't have to but in
just letting them know
gonna talk about it Monday and be very
respectful what's there I was gonna say
that we're not the only ones that think
this though cuz in the comments if you
go through yes a lot of hidden as well
though tuned really there's a lot of
people in there that I saw right
whenever they uploaded it they were like
hey I'd watch steven crowder i watch you
guys lie like both of you why are you
being mean he has a lot of good points
so it's not just us saying it's your
fans watching and seeing it - right yeah
just it seems kind of weird
so doesn't seem weird it seems weird to
people that are fans of theirs and ours
do that yeah and I will say this because
they talked about in their math money
saying I know some people think old big
surprised that you went to LA and now
you're no longer a Christian they try
and cut it off of the past that's
exactly what's happened and I say this
as someone who has lived in California
as someone who has a lot of friends in
California I've seen it happen and by
the way you do have to be honest like
you chose audio way now we're talking
about listen you did choose to go right
to Los Angeles and be a part of
entertainment industry if you wanted to
so it's like someone saying well listen
I don't wear I mean do you think that
I'm just wearing this crest because it
went to this Country Club like I didn't
know I what you wanted to join it you
chose to join that Country Club yeah
that's why you're wearing the crest you
chose to become a part of that industry
in that state and now you're putting on
their team jersey so yeah you may say
you always wanted to do that but that's
why you went to Los Angeles that is
important people you need understand yes
and when you see someone who says I know
people will say this and they try to cut
it off of the past but they don't have a
valid argument that's how you understand
the importance the value of your
surrounding you need to have positive
Association you need to surround
yourself with people not only what I'm
about spiritual issues but people who
will help you elevate your game and all
facets be it physically be it mentally
spiritually emotionally you don't want
to hang around people who turn you into
something you're not or just drag you
down okay I do want to end this on a
positive note are you feeling better are
you coming through yeah I know I'm
feeling pretty good I'm Steve and I just
wanted to say that I'm a realist this is
the first and probably the last time
that I'm gonna be on the show good with
yet with a couple of drops of bourbon
yeah yeah no but I mean I had a great
time this is this is a dream come true
as someone who was a fan before working
on the show
to my father I'm sorry I wanted in all
of this chaos that's been going on a lot
of people don't realize today is Good
Friday right and oh yes their Sunday is
coming up so I just wanted to wish all
of the people out there absolutely
Easter weekend I know this is an it
likely Rita gay by the way they're
saying Easter so and so very happy to be
doing a mass Monday the day after Easter
yeah I really pretty is He is risen and
I know I say some things kind of naughty
sometimes teehee but yeah I'm a
Christian let me leave you with
something that again please do hit the
notification bill because subscriptions
don't mean a whole lot
hit all notifications so you get
notified we have shows of course every
night now it goes up at is it 8 p.m. 8
p.m. Eastern all Western live stream
videos 8 p.m. Eastern every weeknight
and then of course this whole month Mudd
Club quarantine we're doing Monday
Wednesday Friday the morning show which
I hope you enjoy I actually enjoy being
able to do this it's a little more
relaxed and we're able to explore it a
little bit more and promo code is
quarantine $30 off please do consider
joining up if you feel any sense of
community and you know what we're
actually to have a program where you can
buy someone else among club membership
oh yeah so I wanted to tell you a story
that I can't bring Johnny boy in my
Canadian friend but after we did the
Gyeonggi video game stream first off let
me let me preface this this is why I
don't argue when someone calls me a
piece of s word because I do things like
this I went to Taco Bell understandable
no no it's not don't don't don't absolve
me another I'm not I'm saying you make
bad decisions me in a burlap robe
it should be the da Vinci Code just as a
matter of fact I immediately regretted
my decision so when I got home I started
spraying down the bag and then I said
these people aren't gonna follow the
sanitary so I just threw it in the
garbage yeah I got a state
crap supreme and a chalupa I said ah
this is this is no there's no risk this
is not it oh there was a lady who
brightened my night and I want to say
thank you so much this lady and I need
to explain why this was so funny so you
guys all know Johnny boy
yeah have you ever seen him when he like
when he laughs he gets oh not quite as
red as you but he gets really he gets
beat red when he laughs and Abel says
we've targeted Ollie there is nothing
and I knew this going in there's nothing
at Johnny boy he's a ultra white
Canadian a Canadian blood line that he
finds funnier than sassy black women I
don't care it's act like he just find it
so funny like I've talked about
endearing yeah yeah and so we're driving
through Taco Bell and you know it's this
is a sassy black lady and I don't know
how old like she could have been from 30
to 60 I have no idea it's very hard to
guess very judger there so I order a
steak what is it where it's not a
Crunchwrap but it's like wraps but has
like crunchy things in it but it's not
anyway it's all the same time she no
easy gordita crunch even when he's drunk
that for some reason prioritize she's
going to crunch you have a sad lie he
able to walk and talk normally no
gordita yes and his girlfriend is really
something else don't know how he does it
um so that's assume that's what it is we
go cheesy gordita crunch I'll just say
steak Crunchwrap Supremes I'm not gonna
remember all the Taco Bell terms so we
then drive up to the window this is why
it's so funny because from my vantage
point right so you're okay you're me
I'm Johnny okay I see his face and then
we drive up in the window right behind
him as he drives up it is a very large
black woman with long braids dyed red
and severe makeup and surgical gloves
let's just drive up and right away I can
you see John kinda she and this is
nothing but good things we're saying it
brightened our night it's been a tough
week and say what's a sheet so John's
right here and she comes out she goes
huh okay you've got a chicken chalupa
and a steak whatever and ask a crunch I
don't attach Icahn Crunchwrap supreme
and John it's already color huh no no
that was a that was steak and there
she was she was dead when you were
eating chicken and night so I could see
him beat red in the back we're done with
the night and I will leave you with this
she hands us the meal folded very nicely
in a bag on a tray with her surgical
gloves and John is laughing any reason
thank you and she hands it she goes yeah
John was in tears we had to pull over he
was laughing so on social distances
y'all and you know what cultural
differences it is what makes day-to-day
worth living so lady between 30 and or
60 at Taco Bell who made our night I
really appreciate it that's just one of
those silver linings a lot of people
miss what's your silver lining what is
brighten your day comment below let's
keep this a little bit positive same
thing even as it relates to rhett and
Link we'd love to have a conversation
don't be mean because then we end up
being like angry lesbian producer thank
you so much this has been good morning
my club we will see you Monday morning
[Music]